- I think my favorite potent combination
is strength and empathy
and you embody both.
You have grown up in
extraordinary circumstances,
take the Hollywood extraordinary,
most glamorous Academy Award winning,
everything you have lived
an extraordinary life.
You know what real life is all about.
- Listen for you to say that,
I feel that way about you.
We were raised
in maybe not the most
perfect circumstances, right?
Very different.
You were raised right in
the middle of all of this
and I was raised in South Africa,
which couldn't be further away from this
by two parents who had a
road construction company
and I was raised in a
country during a time,
that was filled with a lot of turmoil.
Apartheid. I was raised
during the apartheid era.
I was white and of privilege
and I witnessed how my privilege,
for years while I was a young child,
got me to places that had just
didn't afford to other people
with a different skin color
and it really traumatized me
and then of course I had
my own family issues.
My father was an alcoholic.
He was really sick
and this was at a time when
there was no AA in South Africa,
nobody knew and that in
South African culture,
it's just like what a man does.
And so I was raised in
a lot of things that,
when I look at my kids now,
they're gonna have their
own trauma somehow,
of course, right?
But to have a little bit of calmness
in the home environment,
that's, I think the other reason why
I'm not so eager to
jump into a relationship
because I'm so proud of the fact
that my kids live in a
home where they feel safe
and they feel like
they're never gonna have
to walk on eggshells.
and they're never gonna have to come down
and worry about how their day is gonna go
because mom's boyfriend is not
or I don't want any of that
'cause that's how I was
raised and it's all horrible.
It leaves marks on you for sure.
- My dad was an alcoholic too
and it was because of all
those things that made us
the parents we are today, the women we are
and I'm so grateful for
my wacky circumstances
because they've made me so not a victim
and so demanding of
having goodness around me
and being such a protective lion
and maybe I wouldn't have been like that
had I not seen the crap I saw growing up.
- Yeah. Right.
We'll never know, but I do,
I wanna say this, I love that about you.
I love that you have just made
such a definitive decision
to just go through your
life with joy and happiness
and to actively move towards that
and you do that so, so beautifully.
- Thank you and you fight for others.
You have CTAOP. That's
the event I came to.
That's your organization
that is a fully functioning,
incredible manned organization
that makes massive change in the world
and in South Africa and
in Africa, in general,
the latest cause you have,
will you talk about that?
- CTAOP was kind of
birthed out of what I felt
was a necessity for prevention
care with young people
and at the time it was
really focused on HIV
and AIDS in South Africa.
We're still, unfortunately,
the hardest hit country in the world.
We are 1% of the world's population,
but we represent maybe now
over 17% of the HIV population.
So when COVID happened,
we checked in with all of our
organizations that we support
and the one thing that
kept coming back to us
was that COVID had changed
the world of domestic violence
because what was saving
most of us, staying home,
was a death wish for people
who were in abusive relationships
or abusive families.
They were locked in that danger
place. They can't escape it.
And so domestic violence just skyrocketed.
And so Together For Her
was a platform for us
to just kind of get together
and to spread that message
so that we can support those
grassroot organizations
who were already doing
such important work,
especially doing an epidemic like this.
There's just not enough resources.
- The fact that I'm getting to know you
is like such a highlight of my life
because you are such a
person of depth and soul
and I just have so much admiration for you
and you're just a stone
cold rad brad rad chick,
You're rad.
- I feel that way about you.
I wanna have women around me
who inspire me every single
day and you do that for me,
so thank you.
- I'm really honored
that you came on the show
and when life opens up a little bit,
I would be so thrilled
if our kids get to meet
at being such similar
ages and we can reminisce
about the lion in our life,
Steve Warren, and laugh
and tell fart jokes
and just do our thing.
- I would love that.
Thank you so much, Drew.
- Thank you for your time.
(upbeat music)